we addressed this a little bit ago
in the 1980s interest rates were like
double digits
1981 you know your your
overnight rates were like 18 something
insane
like if you had a mortgage rate you
could have been 15
absolutely now we're less than three yep
okay
so obviously super low interest rates
these days what are the the pros and
cons of this
interest rate you know situation overall
so the the the problem with interest
rates being
held at artificially low levels because
let's understand that's what the fed is
doing
is repressing interest rates the problem
with that
is that now your average home loan
according to mortgage bankers
associations
about 430 000 it's an all-time high
average home loan is 430
000 average purchase application wow
so home prices are at all-time highs
because again
consumers are approaching homes like
they approach cars
all they're looking at is the payment
and the lower your interest rate is
the lower the payment's going to be the
more home you can buy
if interest rates ever rise you're not
going anywhere if interest rates rise
you might lose your home
you might get foreclosed on if they have
an adjustable mortgage or how does it
work with fixed
rates well a fixed rate mortgage
should be tenable but if home prices
fall
because interest rates rise bear in mind
okay so
here's something easy purchase
applications
on thanksgiving 2020 not very long ago
we're up 28
year-over-year i mean housing was
roaring on fire fast forward to the
latest week
purchase applications to buy our home
are up one percent and
on the brink of going negative
year-over-year because we've had a
little move up over three percent in the
30-year fixed
if you buy with an fha loan three
percent down you borrow from your
parents you stretch stretch stretch
and home prices start to fall and
home prices falling are possibly
accompanied by a slowing economy
so if you lose your job or if your
wife's lose her if one of you loses
and all of a sudden you've got this
mortgage you stretch to get into
and you need to get out of the house
mortgage rates are higher you're upside
down on the house
you owe more on it than it's worth
it's very 2008 2009 and yet here we are
scary thought if you if you're if you're
buying too much house if you're buying
too much house okay
um what about the stock market uh what's
your advice
you know that's sort of home but i'm on
the sidelines right now
really i'm not in the stock market right
now you personally are not
i personally am not in the stock market
now i
seed companies so which is even riskier
private equity is much riskier than
public equity
let's be yeah so i am
taking on risks but i can't
wrap my head around valuations and why
stocks are where they are
so i'm i'm on the sidelines so be i'm
just going to read between the lines
here being that you're on the sidelines
does that mean you're expecting the
bubble to burst pretty soon
and well we're starting to see i mean
volatility
the stock the stock market rose back to
all-time highs
post-pandemic right we know that it's
all-time highs right now it's is that a
rough week or two
but in 2017 people people follow the vix
index pretty closely don't they
volatility volatility index so the
volatility how much
stocks can be expected to move going out
in the into the future
in 2017 the vix was in a single-digit
territory 52
record times at the close the prior year
before there was like 1996 1993
it had been like four okay so there was
immense complacency in the market
people did not anticipate that stocks
were going to do anything because the
vix was so
quiet the vix post covet has been north
of 20
for a record stretch so there is anxiety
being exhibited in the market that
there's downside risk
and so that's what you follow you follow
how much
movement is anticipated looking out so
assuming this 1.9
trillion stimulus package oh it's good
it could go right into the stock market
okay so isn't that an indicator
the stock market would go higher sure
and your volatility will probably go
higher as well
but that's still remember you've got
tech stocks
you've got tech stocks that are down for
six months more than the broad average
right now
it's it's very quiet because there's
still all this euphoria out there
but people are starting to lose money so
what's your advice to the average
investor out there i guess let me give
you two scenarios
i haven't even started in the stock
market i don't danielle i don't know
what you're talking about i'm 30 years
old
save your money just save save your
money right now and what about someone
who's
you know 50 60 they're not retired yet
but they're kind of getting there
if they've gotten it though they've got
a half a million dollars in the market
whatever so you need to
you need to pair back that exposure if
you are uh if you're
thinking about living on a fixed income
what do you mean you pay back exposure
go more to bonds
sure so my gold whatever gold
bitcoin i'm not going there
silver silver kiyosaki loves silver
silver is the beauty of silver is it's
precious and it's industrial
oh yeah it's got multiple uses i almost
got a tattoo with silver
i don't have any tattoos i mean based on
kiwisaki i'm like i'm all in on silver
the precious metals complex has really
been beaten up because people believe
that bitcoin's the
the currency of the future but i think
that xi jinping would have something to
say about that
i don't think that he plans on i don't
think china plans on bitcoin taking over
as the reserve currency status i think
china plans on that being their currency
and not giving up control
to something electronic which is why
china's rolling out its own digital
currency right now
whoa so we'll circle back to bitcoin i
know that we don't want to have
an hour-long bitcoin next down the
middle question
danielle dimartino booth host of down
the middle on valuetainment see how that
works out
so by the way i should i should jump in
here for just a second
down the middle is because people who
follow me on social media can't figure
out where i stand
because i try and keep it in the middle
and i think that the middle is what's
been lost in this country
all right so i speak for that moderate
anyway i'm with you let me dap you up to
that one boom
thank you for watching this short clip
if you want to see the full episode
check it out right here and if you have
not subscribed to valuetainment
click right here